the shaman wherever and whenever
he or she does their shamanising
the shaman is a person who is able to transcend
the dimensional confines of cultural existence
the people they serve are
like children within the game of culture
only the shaman knows that culture is a game, everyone else takes it seriously
that's how he can do his magic
you could always tell the shaman, because first of all: he usually didn't come out to see who was there
even though no one ever came, even though these people had visitors once every six months
the guy who wouldn't come out of his hut
for the only event in six months, was inevitably the shaman
and when you met him
he wasn't interested in your velcro, or your break-apart glow-in-the-dark little trampettes
or any of the rest of it
he was looking straight at you
through the eyes
outside of culture
saying 'what kind of a person are you?'
'are you a fool?'
'or are you a clever fella?'
'what is your measure'
'how much of the situation do you understand?'
'how many levels are you simultaneously aware of'
'at this moment?'
and, you know, looking into the eyes of that sort of person, you either grow or turn away